وسط توتر امني وسياسي دعا الاتحاد التونسي
للشغل لاضراب عام الجمعه احتجاجا على
اغتيال القيادي المعارض شكري بعيد بينما
رفضت حركه النهضه اقتراح رئيس الحكومه
حماد الجبالي بتشكيل حكومه كفاءات
وطنيه
نتوقف مع هذا الخبر ناقشه في عنوانين
رئيسيين كيف تفاعلت الساحه السياسيه
التونسيه مع التحديات الامنيه والسياسيه
التي فرضها اغتيال بالعيد وما هو المطلوب
من مختلف الاطراف للوصول الى توافق يمكن
تونس من تجاوز هذه
التحديات
القت عمليه اغتيال القيادي اليساري شكري
بلعيد بظلالها القويه على تونس انفلات
امني في عدد من المدن وردود فعل حاده عمقت
الهوه بين فرقاء الساحه السياسيه ساحه بدت
غامضه الافق اثر اعلان رئيس الوزراء حماد
الجبالي حل حكومته تمهيدا لتشكيل حكومه
تكنوقراط وسط رفض من حركه النهضه التي
للمفارق يمثل الجبالي احد ابرز قيادها اما
المعارضه فقد قابلت خطوه الجبال بتحفظات
بدت في نظر البعض تعجيزيه وسط هذه الاجواء
تاتي دعوه الاتحاد التونسي للشغل لاضراب
عام قد يتحول بدوره الى عامل اخر من عوامل
التوتير قضائيا هي عمليه اغتيال غامضه
تنتظر ان تميت التحقيقات اللثام عن
ملابساتها سياسيا تحولت تصفيه القيادي
اليسار الراحل شكري بالعيد الى زلزال شرع
يعصف بالتوازنات القائمه في الساحه
السياسيه التونسيه رصاصات ارضت اشرس
المعارضين لحكومه ترويكا التي تهيمن عليها
حركه النهضه الاسلاميه ودفعت رئيس الوزراء
حماد جبالي الى اتخاذ قرار مدون يقضي بحل
حكومته وتشكيل حكومه كفاءات مصغره في
بادره لقيت معارضه النهضه الحزب الذي
ينتمي اليه رئيس الحكومه والذي تمسك بان
الظرف السياسي لا يمكن ان تنهض بتعقيدات
سال الدم فتغيرت المعادله بعض اطياف
المعارضه ترفع من سقف خطابها ومطالبها
تحمل النهضه مسؤوليه تصفيه بالعيد وتدعو
الحكومه للاستقاله وتحث على حل المجلس
التاسيسي الذي علقت عضويه نوابها فيه فيما
يدخل انصارها على وقع دعوه الجبهه الشعبيه
للاضراب العام في صدامات عنيفه في مناطق
متفرقه من البلاد اودت في العاصمه بروح
احد افراد الامن الاتحاد العام التونسي
للشغل هو الاخر دعى للاضراب العام يوم
الجمعه كاشفا عن تلقي امينه العام تهديدات
بالقتل قال القيادي في الحزب الجمهوري
احمد نجيب الشابي انه وصلته نسخه مثيله
لها في مشهد فاق ما قلق التونسيين حول
مصير بلادهم وثورتهم التي كثيرا ما فاخر
بسلميتها متسائلين ترى من هي اليد التي
هندست ونفذت عمليه الاغتيال وما هي
الاهداف الحقيقيه من ورائها نددت حركه
النهضه بما وصفته بالمتاجره بدم شكر
بالعيد من قبل اطراف سياسيه قالت انها
تصدرت المنابر الاعلاميه
لتستبين بتصفيه بالعيد دون ما دليل في
خطاب تحريضي تزامن مع حرق عدد من مقرات
الحركه في ارجاء البلاد الرصاصات التي
اودت بحياه بالعيد اعادت توزيع الاوراق
على مشارف المواعيد الانتخابيه المرتقبه
اخبار عن تاسيس جبهه للدفاع عن الشرعيه
تتكون من احز
وحركه وفاء وكتلي الحريه والكرامه
والمستقلين الاحرار في مقابل حديث
المعارضه عن اطر لمزيد تنسيق المواقف
والتحركات بين مكوناتها وبينهما مواطن
يؤكد انه لم يثر يوما لتتحول تونس الى
ساحه للاغتيالات
السياسيه لمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من
تونس الهاشمي طرودي رئيس تحرير جريده
المغربي ومعنا فتحي جراي الاكاديمي المحلل
السياسي وابدا بالسيد الهاشمي الطرودي اما
وقد مضى يوم على اغتيال سيد بلعيد اليوم
كيف تقيم وكيف تراقب تعاطي النخب السياسيه
الاحزاب السياسيه وكذلك مجمل النخب
السياسيه في تونس مع ما جرى البارحه
ويتفاعل حتى
اليوم لقد وقع تنديد بهذه الجريمه النكراء
وادانتها كل نخب السياسيه على
اختلافها سواء كانت ال طريكه الحاكمه او
احزاب المعارضه
ولكن المهم في هذه القضيه هي انها غيرت او
بصدد تغيير المعادله السياسيه في البلاد
حيث ان السيد حماد الجبالي رئيس الحكومه
المؤقته بادر بانه باقتراح مع تشكيل حكومه
كفاءات وطنيه وهذه هي موقع الصراع حاليا
طالبت الجبهه
الشعبيه ومجمل الازاب المعارضه باستقاله
الحكومه هناك بعض الجهات تطالب ايضا بحل
مجلس التاسيسي ولكن ليس ليست هامه لان حتى
الاطراف التي علقت علقت بصفه مؤقته بصفه
احتجاجيه وهذا هو سيد الهاشمي وهذا هو صلب
وهذا هو صلب سؤالي فيما يتعلق بردود الفعل
الدعوه الى حل المجلس التاسيسي الدعوه الى
استقاله الحكومه ردود الفعل هذه كيف
تراقبها
ردود الفعل هذه يجب ان نقول في الحقيقه ان
مبادره السيد حماد الجبالي قد لقيت صدا
مهما
لدى احزاب المعارضه ولدى حتى بعض احزاب
الطريك كتكتل واعتبروها خطوه ايجابيه في
الاتجاه الصحيح لانها تحقق جمله من
الاشياء التي عاقت الى حد الان التحويل
الوزاري وال الذي دام حوالي سبع اشهر وذلك
لانها ستحيي وزارات السياده ولانها س تقوم
ببرنامج عاجل لمواجهه الاوضاع الاقتصاديه
والاجتماعيه ولانها ستحدد خارطه الطريق
لتحديد المواعيد الانتخابيه ولتحديد
معناها الوقت الضروري
لاحداث الهيئات اللي تسمى هيئه التعديلي
كهيئه كهيئه القضاء المؤقت وهيئه الاعلام
والقانون الانتخابي والتشريع بنسق معناها
معناها اعداد الدستور وانهائه في المجلس
سسي بحيث ان هذه البادره يمكن ان تكون
منطلق لكن الحزب الاساسي رفض وهو حزب
السيد حماد الجبالي رفض هذه المبادره
واعتبرها كانها انقلاب على الشرعيه نظر
لان
لان المجلس عن هذه النقطه سيد الهاشمي عن
هذه النقطه وهنا اوجه
سؤالي سيد فتحي جراي فيما يتعلق برد فعل
حركه النهضه سيد فتحي جراي ايضا من ضمن
الافرازات منذ يوم البارحه وحتى اليوم
بالاضافه الى ما قامت به احزاب المعارضه
ايضا هناك افراز جديد يتعلق بما جرى داخل
حركه النهضه بينما قام به رئيس الحكومه
بهذه الدعوه الى حكومه تكنوقراط ورد حركه
النهضه هذا اليوم بالرفض لهذه المبادره
وان تركوا الباب مواربا نحو البحث في سيغ
من خلال الاحزاب السياسيه ماذا عن هذا
الافراز بعد يوم كما قلت من اغتيال شكري
بالعيد
في الحقيقه السيد رئيس الحكومه حينما قام
بمبادرته تلك مساء
امس كان يتوقع كل ردود الافعال الحقيقه
لانه قام بها بوصفه رئيس الحكومه وليس
بوصفه امين عام لحركه النهضه التي تشكل
اهم الاحزاب الثلاثه الحاكمه ولذلك هو
قالها بصريح العباره للتونسيين لم استشر
احدا من الاحزاب السياسيه لا الاحزاب
الحاكمه الاحزاب المعارضه وانما قمت بهذا
العمل بناء على ما املاه علي ضميري
ومسؤوليتي الوطنيه الان طبعا هنالك ردود
افعال متضاربه بطريقه ما ولكنها عموما
هادئه ليست متشنجه انما ربما يكون الطريق
ربما الان سالكا اكثر نحو الحصول على مزيد
من التنازلات من جميع الاطراف قد تكون
مؤلمه بالنسبه لبعض الاطراف
والوصول الى بعض التوافقات
لان يعني هذا الوضع الذي يراوح مكانه
يحتاج الى حل حله السيد رئيس رئيس الحكومه
قام بمبادره اعتقد انها جريئه رغم كل ما
فيها من مجازفه والان طبعا هذه المبادره
حركت ما وصفته سيد فتحي ما وصفته بانه
مجرد مبادره شخصيه من قبل رئيس الحكومه
البعض يرى خلاف ذلك وانما بيقول بان ما
كان يثار في الدوائر المغلقه داخل حركه
النهضه من خلافات الان قد طغى او طفى الى
السطح بما جرى من موقف السيد حمادي
الجبالي وما كان من رد فعل من قبل النهضه
الى اي مدى هذا صحيح
برايك قد يكون ذلك صحيحا ليس لي ان اؤكد
او انفي ذلك ليس لدي المعطيات الكافيه
صحيح ان حركه النهضه حركه يعني ضخمه
مقارنه ربما مع بقيه الاحزاب ولذلك نجد
داخلها عديد التيارات المتنافسه وطبيعي
جدا ان يحصل صراع طبعا ضمن الشروط
المتداوله والمعمول بها اخ الحركه في اطار
عمل طبعا هيئاتها المختصه وخاصه مجلس
شوراها ان يخرج هذا ان يطفو هذا السراع
على السطح هذا ايضا امر عادي اعتقد قد
يكون ذلك مؤشرا ولكن ليس لدي ما يؤكد او
ينفي انما على كل حال هنالك اختلاف و يقول
هذا يقوله حتى النهضويين انفسهم هنالك
اختلاف حول مفردات اداره هذه المرحله بين
اكثر من شق داخل النهضه ولكن ليس ثمه ربما
خلاف او صراع بالمعنى يعني الصارخ للكلمه
انما الرؤه اكيد مختلفه لان المساله معقده
كثيرا وهذا طبيعي جدا في ظل واقع كما قلنا
من التقيد فتحي
جرا
المشهد التونسي ما يجري الان من تجاوزات
امنيه منذ البارحه بشكل مكثف بعد اغتيال
السيد بلعيد شكري بلعيد وايضا ما يتواصل
حتى اليوم هناك انزلاقات امنيه على مستوى
الشارع وهناك احتقان سياسي وتصعيد في سقف
المطالب من قبل المعارضه للسلطه برايك الى
اي مدى قد يؤدي كل هذا سيد الهاشمي
الطرودي قد يؤدي في الحقيقه ان مبادره
مبادره السيد قد فتحت بعض الامل لدى الراي
العام ولكن هناك صعوبه سواء من الناحيه
الدستوريه ومن الناحيه القانونيه لان اذا
كان السيد الجبالي سيقدم حكومه جديده
فعليه ان يقدم استقالته والسيد رئيس
الجمهوريه يكلفه من جديد او يكلف شخصيه
اخرى بتشكيل الحكومه الجديده او ان يقوم
فقط ببعض التعديل ويترك بعض الوزراء
فتقدمها كتعديل وهنا يبدو ان المشهد
السياسي في
في المجلس التاسيسي مقسم بصفه واضحه هناك
المعارضه يمكن ان تقترب وبعض الكتل يمكن
تقترب من مبادره الجبالي وقد تؤيدها بينما
الحزب الحاكم حزب النهضه وحزب السيد
الجبالي وا امينه العام قد بين بصفه واضحه
انه ضد هذه المبادره وانه لم يستشر فيها
وانه متمسك فكره حكومه ائتلاف بينه وبين
الحزبين الاخرين وممكن تساع لاحزاب اخرى
اذا سنعود الى المربع الاول معناها موقف
النهضه الان وموقف حلفائها اذا الذي لم
يتضح بعد يمكن تعيدنا المربع الاول لانها
يمكن ان تشكل يمكن ان تسقط مثلا حكومه
البالي واذا عينت شخصيه اخرى اذا عين مثلا
رئيس جمهوريه جبالي مجددا لتشكيل الحكومه
وتمسك براي فانها ستسقط من جديد وهكذا
تدخل البلاد في دوامه ولهذا ال هناك اليوم
مشاورات كبيره بين رئيس الجمهوريه وكثير
من الشخصيات وربما هناك بعض الحكماء الذين
يمكن ان يلاف لان الوضع محتقن جدا وهناك
ردود فعل
وهناك ظل هذه
الوره اكثر بكثير من من ما هو في ظل هذه
الصوره سيد الهاش وهنا اوجه سؤالي للسيد
فتحي جراي هل الصوره التي سصفها الان طبعا
نتيجه لما جرى البارحه دقيقه والى اي مدى
وان لم تكن دقيقه ف العكس الان حركه
النهضه اقل قوه والمعارضه اكثر اتحاد
واكثر صلابه من ذي
قبل يعني فعلا هو الوضع دقيق ما في ذلك شك
والنهضه هي طبعا الخاسر الاول جراء هذا
الحدث الجلال الذي حل بتونس باعتبار انها
تتحمل ربما العبه الاكبر من الاتهامات
التي توجه الى السلطه الحاكمه بانها ربما
لم تتخذ الاجراءات الكافيه لتلافي مثل ما
حصل على كل حال هي اتهامات فيها كثير من
المبالغه وفيها كثير من الابتزاز السياسي
ولكن مؤكد ان الخاسر الاول من مما حصل هو
النهضه طبعا الاطراف الاخرى قد تربح بعض
النقاط الانتخابيه ولكن هذا كله طبعا
موقفي وا الايام القادمه والاشهر القادمه
هي التي ستحسم ربما حقيقه المواقع التي
يحتلها كل حزب وكل طيف سياسي بالنظر الى
التوافقات التي ستحصل حتما او الاجراءات
الحاسمه التي ستتخذ اما من قبل رئاسه
الحكومه واما من قبل الاحكام الاحزاب
الثلاثه الحاكمه وخاصه اذا نجحت في توسيعه
توسيع دائره التحالف ومن ثم فرض نفسها ك
ربما يعني اغلبيه برلمانيه داخل المجلس
التاسيسي تستطيع ان تفرض بطريقه ما شكل
الحكومه القادمه لو يعني قدر ان تشكل
حكومه جديده وهذا هو
الارجح في ظل هذه الظروف كيف يمكن العبور
بتونس من هذه الازمه هذا ما سنناقشه بعد
فاصل قصير تفضلوا بالبقاء
معنا اهلا بكم من جديد في هذه الحلقه التي
تناقش مالات الاوضاع في تونس في ضوء
الواقع السياسي والامني الحالي سنحاول
فيما تبقى من هذه الحلقه ان نناقش افاق
الحل او افاق التوافق بين مختلف الاطراف
السياسيه في تونس واجدد تحيه بضيفي من
تونس السيد الهاشمي والسيد فتحي سيد
الهاشمي في ظل هذا الواقع الذي يوصف بانه
يبلغ مستويات معينه من التصعيد بين مختلف
الاطراف ما هو الطريق الى الحل الى
التوافق بين هذه الاطراف
برايك الوضع يبده ضبابي ومعقد وصعب ليس من
السهل تماما لان ثم احدى حلين معناها
يبدوان في الوفق اما ان تتنازل حركه
النهضه والتركه ل موقف جبالي وبذلك يمكن
ان يقع نوع من الاجماع حول الحكومه الت
سيشكلها جبالي وهذه تبدو حل مهم ولكنه صعب
المنال قد يؤدي الى نهايه هذه المرحله
الانتقاليه مع هو عمليه الانتقال
الديمقراطي والوصول الى حكم دائم وال
الاختيار الاخر هو ان حركه النهضه تتمسك
بموقفها وهي لا تعد بالاغلبيه فان استيع
بشكل اغلبيه جديده حتى لو خرج بعض احزاب
التريك مثل التكتل فان لها دعم وفاء هي
عندها 9 مقعد وهناك وفاه تقريبا 10 مقاعد
وهناك كتل الحريه والكرامه عند تقريبا 10
مقاعد بحيث تستطيع تصل الى الاغلبيه ولكن
المشكله ان مشكله سياسيه كبرى لان هناك
التصعيد في الحياه السياسيه هناك سقف
مطالب كبرى للمعارضه هناك تاكيد على ان
معناها النهضه لها مسؤوليه سياسيه حتى قبل
نهايه التحقيق في تصاعد العنف الذي ادى
الى اغتيال الشهيد
بعيد معى اذا فهناك لا يمكن ان ان تجعل
تسويه سياسيه او حل حله سياسيه ولكن يمكن
ثم من الناحيه السياسيه هناك ا ضعف لان
لان وفاء قريبه ايديولوجيا للنهضه وكتله
الحريه والكرامه ليس لها هويه سياسيه بحيث
النموذج تونسي الذي تفتقر به النهضه
وتقوله نموذج تعايش بين الاسلاميين وبين
علمانيين سيسقط وا ونعرف ان العامل
الخارجي ايضا والراي العام الخارجي وشركاء
تونس ينظرون الى التجربه التونسيه نظره
معينه فاذا
انفرضت نهضه بهذا الحل فان هناك فكره على
انها ان هناك حزب واحد يحكم تونس وان فكره
التعدديه وفكره التعايش يمكن ان ان تسقط
وهذا هو الخطر اذا هذا هذا هو التعقيد طيب
الان الان الان هناك هناك خبر سيد سي هناك
خبر عاجل يتعلق باقتراح من مؤسسه الرئاسه
التونسيه بتشكيل حكومه توافق وطني واسناد
الحكومه او الوزارات التقنيه الى ذوي
كفاءات او تكنوقراط وكان يبدو حل وسط بين
ما كان يناقش سياسيا او طرح على مستوى
النهضه من قبل السيد الراجل ارشد غنوشي
وما قاله في الاخير السيد حمادي الجبالي
سيد فتحي الى اي مدى قد يكون هذا حل
برايك يعني الوهله الاولى يبدو هذا الحل
واقعيا ومنطقيا وحافظا لماء وجه الجميع
وربما مرضيا للجميع ومن ثم مدعاه للتوافق
الوطني وعلى اي حال هو مهما يكون شكل
الحكومه القادمه والصيغه التي ستشكل بها
فاهم من ذلك هو ان يقع الاتفاق على اهم
المواعيد والاستحقاقات القادمه وتحديدها
بتواريخها محدده والتعجيل طبعا بكتابه
الدستور والتصديق عليه من قبل المجلس
الوطني التاسيسي واحداث الهيئات التعديلي
والقانون الانتخابي لان هذا هو مركب
النجاه وهو هذا هو
ربما يعني طوق الامان الذي تلقيه الحكومه
و
المجلس التاسيسي باعتباره السلطه الاصليه
للناس للشعب حتى يشعروا بالامان و
يعني يترقب بربما بكثير من الاطمئنان
المرحله القادمه وهي المرحله الدائمه لان
هذه الحكومه والحكومه التي سبقتها وحتى ما
قبلها يعني ظلت تعاني دائما من نوع من
الشرعيه المنقوصه بسبب صيغه او وصف المؤقت
او المؤقت التي تلصق بها وهذا طبعا
يجعلها معناها تفتقر لشيء من
ربما السلطه المعنويه على الناس ومن ثم
تظل مرتبكه الى حد ما في اداره الشان
العام السيد الهاشمي هذه الايام توجه
الكثير من الضغوط والاتهامات لحركه النهضه
ولكن ماذا عن ثقل المعارضه البعض يقول وان
كانت الان المعارضه موحده فيما يتعلق
بموقفها من السلطه او ما يتعلق بما جرى
للسيد شكري بالعيد ولكن هذه المعارضه ايضا
تعاني من كثير من الخلال ومن اختلافات في
الرؤى وبالتالي السؤال عن ثقل هذه
المعارضه حتى نتصور شكل التوافق مع السلطه
او مع حركه النهضه
بالاساس لا شك ان حادث الاغتيال هذا سيوحد
المعارضه ويكون هناك تقارب بين ما يسمى
بمكونات العائله الديمقراطيه هذا شيء اكيد
ونحن يمكن اتجه الى نوع من جبهه الانقاذ
شبيهه بجبهه الانقاذ الموجوده في مصر منها
تضم الليبراليين واليساريين والقوميين
ومختلف التوجهات السياسيه غير اسلاميه وفي
المقابل تكون هناك عائله اسلاميه او جبهه
اسلاميه هذا الشيء خطير في الحقيقه نحن لا
نريد بلادنا ان تنزلق اليه لكن اعتقد اعود
الى
الى الى مقترح رئيس الجمهوريه فان مقترح
جيد لو يقع لانه يوفر امرين اساسيين الامر
الاول هو ان حكومه وحده وطنيه ستكون
الحكومه الجديده مسنوده من كل القوه
السياسيه وتكون المهمه الباقيه في المرحله
الانتقاليه هي مهمه اصليه وليست مهمه
معارضه
وحكومه
ونا كلها سيلتون حول
هذه الحكومه وحول برنامجها الذي هو سيغطي
محطات ما تبقى بالمرحله الانتقاليه والامر
الثاني المهم الذي يمكن ان نبعث الاطمئنان
لدى الناس والذي يحملون النهضه مسؤوليه
سياسيه على الاقل بامر هو تحييد معناها
وزارات السياده التي تلقى انتقادا كبيرا و
مسؤوليه كبيره فيما حدث وفيما يحدث في
قضايا اخرى وهي وخاصه وزارتي الداخليه
والعدل م يعتبر في الحقيقه اذا حضي
بموافقه الاطراف السياسيه الفعليه يكون حل
مثالي ويكون منقذ الوضع
و مخرج سليم لانه بالحديث سيد هاشميه ا
بين بين سياسيه الحكومه وبين الكفاءه
التكنوقراطيه التي ستعطى لوزارات السياده
حتى لا يكون هناك تجاذبات او استغلال لهذه
الوزارات في العمليه الانتخابيه وتكون
العمليه اكثر شفافيه واكثر الكثير سي فحي
سيد فتحي جراي الكثير يربط بين ما يجري
وسواء من تحركات سياسيه او ما يجري على
الارض ويربطه بالانتخابات القادمه
المتوقعه في
الصائفة حادثه مثل التي حدثت البارحه
للسيد شكري بلعيد قلبت الاوراق وادخلت
البلد في هذا المازق والكثير من السياسيين
التونسيين قالوا بانه قد وصلهم بلاغات
تهديد
بالقتل ماذا عن مستقبل تونس في ظل هذه
التهديدات وهذا
الواقع طبعا يعني المساله يلفها كثير من
الغموض وهذه البلاغات او التهديدات التي
تاتي في شكل رسائل قصيره او ما اشبه ذلك
هي بمثابه الاحجيه التي تؤرق الجميع اعتقد
يعني المعنيين بها مباشره والمسؤولين في
السلطه والناس عموما الذين يشعرون في ظل
هذه يعني الاحداثيات عن يشعرون بنوع من
تخلخل الامن الاجتماعي اما عن مستقبل
الوطن
فالمسالة
حشر فئه معينه او طيف سياسي معين في
الزاويه والالتفاف ضده او العكس وعدم
الانقسام على اساس ربما
ايديولوجي يساري ضد اسلامي او ليبرالي ضد
يساري او سواه يعني هذا طبعا لا يخدم الان
المصلحه الوطنيه وخاصه في هذه المرحله
الانتقاليه لان الاوضاع ما تزال جراي
الاكاديمي والمحلل السياسي شكرا جزيلا لك
وكذلك اشكر ضيفي السيد الهاشمي الطرودي
رئيس تحرير جريد المغربي كنتما معي من
تونس بهذا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما
وراء الخبر نلتقي باذن الله في قراءه
جديده فيما وراء خبر جديد الى اللقاء باذن
الله